Rupert Murdoch is stepping down as chair
of fox and News Corp
the company said the 92 year old media
Baron would exit his roles when they
hold annual meetings in November in a
memo to staff Murdoch wrote for my
entire professional life I have been
engaged daily with news and ideas and
that will not change but the time is
right for me to take on different roles
the one word that does not appear in
either the announcement or in Rupert's
memo to staff is the r word retirement
people who talk to him say he still is
active and engaged and curious as ever
so it'll be interesting to see just how
much he is able to take his hands off
the steering wheel his eldest son
Lachlan Murdoch will become the sole
chair of News Corp and continue as
executive chair and CEO of Fox Murdoch
called his son a passionate principled
leader who can take the companies into
the future I think this is a big deal
for Lachlan obviously he's well versed
in all the companies but now at least
officially on those boards he's the
chair of both and there is not a large
Shadow over him he'll be the one in
theory sitting at the corner seat Rupert
Murdoch built his media Empire over
seven decades changing news and
entertainment as one of the world's most
influential and controversial figures
what keeps you at it
I just love it it's it's the you know I
have busy very busy days and it keeps me
stimulated keeps me curious
that's the way to stay young he
inherited a small Australian newspaper
business I love it I'm a romantic about
you and built it into a Colossus he
acquired the news of the world the Sun
the times of London and the New York
Post he later launched the Fox network
which broke through with franchises like
The Simpsons and NFL football and
reshaped U.S cable news with Fox News
when we can firmly announce the starting
of a Fox News channel in 2007 Murdoch
sealed a deal to buy the Wall Street
Journal publisher Dow Jones for five
billion dollars Rupert is a very
obviously polarizing figure to many
people with his views with the views of
the editorial pages of both the
newspapers he owns and the cable
channels he runs he mingles among world
leaders has an influence far beyond just
his media companies Murdoch continues to
be a major shareholder in both Fox and
News Corp I've been covering this
company too long to be surprised by
anything or to look at anything is
written in stone Rupert Murdock has
built an Empire that is constantly
changing constantly moving parts around
both in terms of the companies he owns
sells acquires and the people running it
often they're like pieces on a
chessboard at this moment the only other
Murdoch inside the Empire with his hands
in both companies is Lachlan Murdoch but
this is a long game and so we will see
ultimately how this all shakes out
oh